well we've heard a lot about long covet
the long-term effects some people have
from the coronavirus
but now there is new research revealing
more about the psychological impact too
denise valdez joins us live with the
details in today's health watch hey
denise
well hi there christian as you know
scientist at the oxford university found
that people diagnosed with covid19 are
at a
greater risk of developing really a
range of both psychological
and neurological conditions in fact one
in
three cobit patients in this country
develop brain or psychiatric disorders
within six months of being infected
so for instance here ivan agarton he's
an adventure photographer
but when he returned from his latest
assignment he was diagnosed with covid
however his symptoms were pretty mild so
he wasn't really too concerned
until he became incredibly paranoid even
hearing voices right outside his window
it instantly like a light switch i felt
this intense paranoia hit me
i couldn't escape it it kept every
single person that i saw would trigger
this
this intense fear welp doctors
eventually linked it to his condition
with cobit
further study found that copin patients
were treated more often for a range of
disorders from common things like maybe
anxiety and depression
to rare conditions like dementia and
psychosis but
they still don't know why is this for
example a direct effect of the virus
getting into the brain and damaging the
brain
is it inflammation in the brain well
months later agarton says he's
vaccinated he's feeling better
he hopes that sharing his story will
give others courage to just go ahead and
ask for help
uh scientists also found that the sicker
people got from cobit
the more likely they were to develop
some of these mental health
complications
this is really just more proof that we
still have a long way to go to
understanding this virus